le moment est solennel pour le
gouvernement cette prolongation donnant
est plus qu'une formalité
il ouvre un nouveau front la scierie de
croyant que la tâche d'un mec ne devrait
plus plus pouvoir trouver refuge en
syrie
les avions de chasse canadiens seraient
donc autorisé à bombarder le groupe armé
état islamique de l'autre côté de la
frontière irakienne
là où il a regroupé ses ressources et
infrastructures
seulement en plein coeur de la guerre
civile sanglante qui déchire la cible
depuis quatre ans
ce n'est pas avec une escale à lutter
pour l'opposition
récit lui est une ligne rouge à ne pas
franchir car des frappes contre le
groupe a remis état islamique aurait
pour effet d'affaiblir le principal
foyer de la rébellion contre le régime
assad et des donc est directement ce
dictateur accusé de crimes de guerre
contre sa population civile nous ne
pouvons pas apporter notre soutien à une
mission qui pourrait très bien
consolider le pouvoir d'assad en syrie
le gouvernement se défend prévaloir
qu'il ne sollicitera pas l'appui du
régime assad que l'intervention il sera
strictement aérienne qu'aucune force
spéciale sera déployé au sol
quand bowling déstabiliser affaiblir le
groupe a remis état islamique est devenu
essentiel pour assurer la sécurité des
canadiens
l'état islamique a clairement indiqué
qu'ils ciblent énormément le canada et
les canadiens et pour l'opposition cette
mission demeure vague sans objectifs
clairs le une cuisine prévient qu'il y
mettra fin s'il est élu
parti libéral trudeau officiellement on
recentrerait cette mission autour d'un
rôle davantage humanitaire et oui
éventuellement rappeler les cf-18 au
pays
emmanuel l'otan en octobre dernier le
gouvernement proposait une mission
restreinte autant là il vise beaucoup
plus grand ça pourrait être un point
tournant pour le canada absolument parce
que au début l'objectif c'est de freiner
d'affaiblir le groupe armé état
islamique à l'horloge que l'a carrément
le gouvernement parle de le défaire de
l'anéantir le premier ce qui soutient
qu'il faudra que l'intervention
militaire dure tant que la menace ne
sera pas éradiqué donc si le vote
portent sur un déploiement de 12 mois on
sent que l'objectif du gouvernement est
à beaucoup beaucoup plus long terme faut
ajouter aussi céline qu'à certains
égards la proposition du gouvernement
est vague à souhait on a beau parler ce
soir d'irak et de syrie
le texte de la motion souligne on
pourrait frapper l'état islamique peu
importe où se trouvent ses
infrastructures et ses opérations et si
le premier ministre a dit le quai pas
question d'envoyer des troupes au sol
en même temps il se lève une toute
petite porte ouverte en citant
finalement la proche des etats-unis le
président obama dit qu'il faut éviter si
possible une intervention au sol est est
ce que les conservateurs ont servir de
tous en campagne électorale est ce que
ça va devenir un enjeu électoral
ça semble clairement le pari du
gouvernement de camper monsieur un peu
comme le leader qui osent se tenir droit
sans compromis osent affronter la menace
du groupe armé et thaïs lamic pour les
canadiens vous savez si le gouvernement
dit qu'il veut l'appui de l'opposition
n'y a absolument rien fait pour tenter
de l'obtenir c'est quand même un débat
important cette notion là l opposition
leur su ça quelques heures at-elle de
préavis
un débat un peu à la dernière minute et
surtout cette question de la syrie tout
donc pour empêcher le npd ou le parti
libéral de changer d'idée d'appui au
gouvernement merci beaucoup emmanuel au
revoir
je poursuis maintenant avec charles
philippe david titulaire de la chaire
raoul dandurand en études stratégiques
et diplomatiques
on cherche à voir ce lien alors le
gouvernement compte mener ses frappes en
syrie sans l'accord explicite de la
série comme le font les états unis est
ce que ça tient la route sur le plan du
droit international sur les plages de
internationale sans doute pas parce que
il serait beaucoup mieux d'avoir une
résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu pour une intervention militaire
dans un pays lorsqu'il n'y a surtout pas
l'accord du pays ont ce n'est pas le cas
évidemment parce que il y à des blocages
au niveau du conseil de sécurité la
russie et la chine notamment qui ne sont
pas d'accord avec une intervention
occidentale en syrie mais là évidemment
on peut être un peu cynique c'est que
bachar el-assad n'est pas tout à fait
mais content de cette intervention dans
la mesure où une intervention aérienne
contre le groupe armé état islamique
affaibli ce dernier est au fond
satisfait son propre son propriétaire et
donc est ce que l'opposition a un peu
raison de dire qu'on ferait le jeu de
bachar al assad
oui parce que évidemment prendre en
compte ce qu pourront se préoccupent
devrais je dire de groupes armés état
islamique qu'on ne se préoccupe pas de
ce qui se passe ni pour les syriens ni
pour l'avenir du gouvernement syrien et
les jours donc de bachar el-assad sont
prolongées d'autant qu'on se préoccupe
de cette question du groupe armé de
l'état islam et puis j'aimerais dire que
la situation en syrie qu'on peut par
différentes que celles de l'irak alors
qu'on a des alliés au sol terrestre en
irak nommément évidemment gouvernement
irakien et les kurdes mais aussi le
gouvernement iranien qui aident en sous
main à un miracle si les positions de la
syrie de personnes sur le terrain pour
intervenir en syrie or nitti le
gouvernement de bachar el-assad ont
imaginé un peu la situation
le dilemme moral dans lequel le canada
se retrouve de bombarder en syrie ce qui
a aidé le gouvernement de bachar
el-assad et en même temps fait son jeu
effectivement alors le canada deviendra
le seul pays de l'otan avec les états
unis a bombardé la série le royaume uni
a refusé de le faire
est-ce que c'est pas un peu risqué pour
le canada justement de calquer sa
politique sur celle des états unis je
pense que oui parce que ça affaiblit
d'autant l'identité de la politique
étrangère canadienne le gouvernement le
monsieur harper je pense qu mais deux
bévues la première c'est celle de trop
aligné ses positions sur celle des états
constamment la réponse militaire en
particulier est toujours privilégiée sur
toutes les autres et surtout
deuxièmement je pense que là où le bât
blesse ne pas expliquer à la population
canadienne
une adresse à la nation un grand
discours pourquoi comment le canada
intervient-il avec quels objectifs et
quel espoir de résultat et je pense
qu'une discussion franche
un exposé fera de la situation serait
vraiment ce moment ci souhaitant pas
seulement au parlement est un point
tournant pour le canada merci beaucoup
charles-philippe pas je vous en prie